carolina hat preuß mitgespielt zu haben
in dieser folge auf jeden fall ja also
ich müsste lügen wenn ich sage ich bin
total stolz drauf und so habe ich
beweisen dass wir auf jeden fall mit
gespielt sondern herzen kommen viele
leute gekommen zu teil 2 des interviews
mit marcel leute falls es noch nicht
wusste marcel hat bei ep mitgespielt und
zwar weil zwei von denen meist
aufgerufenen folgen aller zeiten
es gibt wie gesagt schon ein interview
teil eins jetzt macht das aber jetzt
erst mal zuerst ist der erste link und
eine beschreibung der ansonsten jetzt
let's go wird viel spaß sorgen mucki 09
09 was war das geräusch liste andré die
kosten tatsächlich war echt hart
beschreibt diese ja die stadt zudem ja
ist ja auch nicht falsch gewesen
es war für mich schon nicht hatten also
ok also es geht halt mal zu küssen der
mann nicht per se sagen würde aus
welchem grund auch immer sicher und das
muss mein typ sondern wo man in der
situation des bundes national einfach
und wir natürlich in dem moment gefühlt
wir haben sie hat so schlecht nina k t
energie ums geld oder um den spaß
eigentlich linie um den spaß aber
beihilfen mir das geld an christi haben
nicht die produzenten zu irgendetwas
gedrängt das so will ich jetzt nicht
sagen gedrängt es ist halt sehr viel
medienpsychologie also ich find die
medienpsychologin für hilfen wir
zuständig und die manipulieren die ich
finde ich schon kann ja so wenn ich
sagen er macht das doch mal
ja nee das mach ich ganz sicher nicht ja
nie wir brauchen es nur für einen tag
aber das wird dann raus geschnitten und
das werden wir auch gar nicht so und
wenn du das sagst was hat schon ist in
meine texte zum beispiel ich sollte sich
schlechter sprechen also du drückst du
soll das mehr als designer genau also
ich sollte jetzt zb nicht sagen so er
kam erst machen
hey was machst du da also so richtig
weiß die zwingend ein geschlecht
zuschauer also eigentlich nur so und ich
erkläre es immer so eigentlich wollen
sie so dass die abtastung auf die haben
stadt und sagt was tust du denn hier so
richtig schlecht eintracht ja und wir
wollen ja das niveau ganz mithalten nein
weil es wollen ja die leute auf
produzieren das ist ja das ziel ist dass
der nation dafür dass das hätte ich
jetzt nicht mehr gehabt dass leute
gezwungen werden schlitz zuschauer man
muss aber sie kommen von selbst beim 1 1
weil mein eigentlichen dreharbeiten es
ist ja ein bisschen mehr emotionen und
deshalb sind weniger bisschen weniger
schrecklich gar nicht so arg ist ein
schlechter tag genau ist bisschen
schwerer und weniger emotionen genau
carolina hat bereust du es mit gespielt
sondern in dieser folge auf jeden fall
ja also ich müsste lügen wenn ich sage
ich bin total stolz drauf und so habe
ich beweisen der fall wir auf jeden fall
gespielt
das aber könne man muss ehrlich sein
bruder asphalt gefüllt dass man selbst
in die rolle einbringen also jetzt zum
beispiel ich meine hier gemeint der text
ist gar nicht so fest vorgeschrieben
aber andererseits kriegst du schon viel
in sachen schlecht zu machen
adina als weiterhin augen also ich den
text kann ich euch wirklich zurecht
legen aber er wird dann durch die
regisseurin wenn man die option enten
kann schon verbessern sagen ja nie das
braucht es gar nicht sagen
irgendwas habe ich mal gesagt ich glaube
da ist es gar nicht essentielle oder
sogar leicht land bloß keine fachwerk
findet es kennen unsere zuschauer gar
nicht wissen erst mal googeln und so ist
es echt also muss da wirklich ganz unten
drehen
richtig es ist länger einfach normale
wolltest du zwischendurch aussteigen
nicht weiter drehen ja noch ganz am
anfang habe
wie gesagt ich werde sie nicht
weitermachen ob wie und was dann
passiert er den vertrag vorgehalten hier
ist ja schon mal hier die klausel da bei
unserer zeitung und dem ausfall 13.000
euro oder ich weiß gar nicht wie viel
zwar habe es jedoch attraktiv sagt ist
also setzen wir an dass die pistole auf
die brust genau gute manchmal sehr gut
ich hätte mir vor durch natürlich aber
wenn du es weißt serien kennt und ihr
vertrauter fragen von mir ist wie ist
das verhältnis heute zu der dann hat es
darunter gelitten unterliefen dreht also
zu der rechnung zu haben
ich hab sie ich glaube eher nicht
bewusst auch seitdem nie wieder
kontaktiert weil sie ihr euch musste
sich vor dem feuer geschlossen und man
hat sich dann selbst von dem man ja
nicht so gefallen hat immer von den
dreien fahren bekommen wöchentlich sogar
und seit dieser folge kein einsehen
chris o'neill auch fragt stört mich wenn
leute über mich lachen weil die serie
sei überhaupt nicht nein also ich
erkannt du hast ja du hast ja auch die
menschen darüber gemacht hast du so mit
lachen ich muss ja auch als die serie
gesehen habe was für ein spaß
überhaupt nicht es kann auch von über
mich selber lachen und nevis ständig
antalya läuft 15 was verdienst war sie
jetzt nicht und irgendwie also sprich so
viel wie du darüber sprechen will ist
also alles ok also komplett top secret
ja das problem ist halt man weiß ja nie
wer schaut sich das anders weil sie
ihren vertrag eine ganze klausel dass du
niemals über den über die ganze rede und
dann über den deutschen mit mit
schauspielern am set also jedoch nicht
mal gegenseitig austauschen was sie für
die garage kommen wenn du jetzt sagen
wir das was sie gerade dann musst du
zehn millionen zahlen wahrscheinlich
ungefähr aber ich kann sagen ich hab mir
und die habe ich mir in zweiwöchigen
spannenden und lässt ok ich konnte
überhaupt habe das team gezeigt heute
hier fünf millionen aufrufe zu fördern
und er hat jetzt dass ich da einfach nur
warum ist die rocker warum perfekt
geschrieben
darum ja einfach mal junge vertrag vor
genau das hat paula 12 6 castries
anbeginn des drehs bewusst das hilft mir
eine sachorientierte tatsächlich nicht
ich habe es wirklich da vorher nie
gesehen oder wenn es diese natürlich
schaue diesem trächtige zuerkannt
aber hätte ich gewusst hätte ich nicht
mal wie man die menschen angst macht ihm
die waren eigentlich ganz nett
eigentlich ganz nett aus den die
regisseurin die mannschaft sind wir eben
die zustimmung oder so die hat uns halt
immer wirklich als dumm verkauft aber ja
ich habe guten grund hat die reden wie
die regisseurin hat wie hat euch gewiss
oder ja sehr verwenden weil halt
irgendwas war und ich habe ihm gesagt ja
wie soll ich das umsetzen und wir sind
wir voll in der und hat immer so
gehalten richtige um also ich erkläre
dir nochmal und hat sich wirklich von
auf das wesen der dümmste mensch der
welt es gibt eben ganz ganz komischen
eindruck ab oder soziale sowie man haben
dann führt sie auch wirklich umgesetzt
ehrlich sein das ist perfekt für die
optimale serie ja vielleicht irgendwo
dass ich die menschen fühlt desto besser
nochmal latrinen bist du danach
bekannter geworden
die haben negativen sinne bestimmen wie
wir sind also wie kommen wir doch nichts
beschreibt das mal so also wie ist der
anteil von
spritzig und wie wir es anders sein ja
es ist glaube ich immer so ja die leute
sind ja immer so ins gesicht sagen sie
dir nix aber hintenrum lassen
der crafter sander wenn ich persönlich
angesprochen wurde haben die leute immer
gefeiert
oder halt nicht aber das habe ich mit
bekommen also persönlich habe ich es nie
negativ aber hinter dem rücken und
gelästert
das weil es wird gehemmt und auf der
straße ab und gcd bist du wirklich so
grün
genauso würde ich jetzt schon überhaupt
stimmt dass ich damit gemacht auf jeden
fall aber nein jetzt im normalen leben
oder so nein hier ist die frage von emma
das wird ein arbeitsumfeld l geht bei
der auszahlung also das jetzt zur
zahlung gearbeitet wo das genau welche
in der ausstellung macht man fertig und
war dann tatsächlich ich bin kein
pflegerin kann muss um eine
pflegedienstleitung hat mir im büro
geholt weil sie gesagt hat ich hätte ja
das anmelden müssen
also du musst das ja den arbeitgeber
anmelden irgendwie passt das war's aber
danach haben wir gelacht und gefeiert
aber wie viele andere
ich würde das nur irgendwie so bist du
denn deine arbeitsrechtlichen
vorschriften aber jetzt hast du bist das
unternehmen hat sich ganz anderen kader
ist aber es ist nicht so dass wir sagen
sofort gekündigt
gar nicht genau wissen zudem unterstrich
xrx war hilft mir den letzten willen zu
kommentieren bradshaw direkt nach meiner
ausbildung ich habe gerade ein auto
gekauft ich dachte hey komm alles ist ja
in dem moment schon jetzt bis heute wie
dies ablehnen weil wir zur ausbildung
sind sogar schon sonja zog sofort bei
den charakteren wenn er dort spielen
musste in wirklichkeit gehen würdest du
jetzt gibt es irgendwelche ähnlichkeiten
da nicht mal was ihr dazu noch sagen
muss hilft mir ist natürlich auch so
wenn er irgendwas perfekt sitzt denn
haare sitzen denn die irgendwie
verstellt bei mir was ja tatsächlich so
das war diese erbfolge damit hatte ich
mich ein herzensthema schmeckt hier in
der mitte gespielt wie an geschminkt und
hat diese ich weiß dass war
maskenbildnerin noch zur der regisseurin
gesagt hat es kommt eigentlich auf die
seite wenn mein herz haben meistens auf
der seite und die regisseurin hätten sie
mit dem genauer hiermit haben und es hat
echt angetan hat als warnung die
verführung 40 minuten bis das andere
also solltet eure das finde ich komplett
geisteskrank ist hier das ist
tatsächlich so einen guten halt echt
scheiße gemacht und die wollen ja sogar
dass ich mir also die wollten dass ich
mir die spitzen wenn dir selber
schneiden oder schneiden lassen das ist
halt nicht
die frisur aber das ist krass mit
geschminktem ihr habt das ist doch die
folge weiß ich nicht ob ich die kennen
die hat er auch total hübsches gesicht
und die haben wir hier sind erstmal die
macht der sonne war zeuge wird und
welcher welt wir los fragt ob er noch
mit dem west trimmrad kontakte nein nein
habe ich nicht mehr ich habe nie
wiedergesehen kontakt gehabt die
geschrieben oder weniger an und ich
hoffe dass sie nicht irgendwo
wir wünschen dass ihre karten fallen
wdr dürftest du mit entscheiden was
gezeigt wird
im gegenteil mir gesagt das machen
daraus das machen wir aus brauchen wir
nur für einen schnellen schnitt 40 so
ist nämlich meistens wenn man dreht die
neben szene auf weil er wissen wollen
deswegen im ärztehaus löschen das ist
das geilste klar dass ich macht man
paula punkt weber hast du deine
angehörigen davon erzählt lebt
allerdings treffen die bekommt es dann
mit zwei arbeitskollegen anderen
familienmitglieder mein kleiner bruder
ist ganz vollendet wird
der schickt so lieb familie prof der
spaß beim zuhören da ist ganz schnell
alles draußen also eine eigene familie
steht da auf gar keinen fall hinter dir
sondern optisch auch bereichen so muss
das denn der seite von jessica
verschiedene 2 woher kennst du erst geld
also wie bist du auf ihn aufmerksam
geworden
er wollte unbedingt dass ich nach köln
kommen das war seit ich habe dann
geschrieben weil ich mir dachte er
bemerkte gemacht und ich fand es seien
aber einfach die beste viele haben ja
jacksons gemacht und ich fand sie
einfach überhaupt nicht lustig aber
essen sie gemacht hat ich habe mir so
den arsch abgelassen das ist das ist
eine wirklich ich dachte mir einfach ne
finde ich mega cool und ja danach habe
ich gern wie sonst und jähriger ist
wegen sind sich heute hier wäre und
damit heute geht auch schon der zweite
teil des interviews zur international
noch mal vielen dank herr korrekt das
total preisträger feiere ich wie gesagt
heute marcels kanäle sind und fragt er
macht jetzt auch youtube hat auch
inszenieren deswegen jack dietrich
vorgeschlagen dass wir jungen könnte
meinen kabinen leute jetzt was
willkommen